pour assurer la sécurité des visiteurs
les promeneurs du jardin de l'état le
conseil départemental a décidé d'abattre
un vieux ficus malades dont les branches
menace de tomber à tout moment
il organise avec l'équipe de masse car
en tout un programme autour de ce
dernier rien n'est perdu puisque on a on
a pu redonner vie en fait à cette arme
était vraiment le message que voulait
donner le conseil départemental
c'était 2 voilà un arme parce qu'il est
malade mais on fait l'effort on est on
est sensible à obo public qui côtoie cet
art depuis très longtemps et on prend
l'initiative d'anticiper justement voilà
ce sentiment de peine par rapport à
l'abattage de l'arbre est un on propose
un accompagnement pédagogique pour faire
en sorte de lui redonner vie donc à
cette initiative très très sensible en
fait finalement pour pour le public
jardin et à un accompagnement
pédagogique qui se poursuit avec les
deux mêmes classes de collégiens
sensibiliser quelques jours auparavant
on est ici pour expliquer les choses aux
élèves pour pour un peu expliqué dans
quelles démarches inscrit cette action
on est là on n'est pas là uniquement par
abattre à un art on est là pour en
reporter un autre donc c'est le cycle de
la vie aulas ici sur leurs gardes
une partie de la branche
j'ai fait du bouturage et j'ai planté
des déracinés des racines des branches
d'un arbre qu'on a on est on est en
train de couper parce que il était
malade il avait une maladie et on est en
train de refaire ses branches pour avoir
le même banc de mai en sang est malade
on a appris les pleins comment couper
les plantes au témoin parce que c est
aller est déjà malade le rock l'as
étaples pour pour multiplier
m
fait
une démarche appréciée par les élèves
ravis de cette nouvelle expérience
on a proposé en fait une technique de
multiplication en fait par bouturage du
ficus alors il existe plusieurs
techniques donc on a proposé quatre
techniques de bouturage et boutures en
crosse est les boutures à talons les
boutures de tête et les boutures simple
et c'est qu'un type de boutures et bien
on les a plantés soit dans de la terre
soit dans l'eau soit on ajouté de
l'hormone soit on a fait ce qu'on
appelle une bouture à l'étouffée pour
pouvoir vraiment balayé tout le champ
des possibles en terme de deux
techniques de bouturage et pour essayer
d'être sûr qu'ils aient une bouture qui
fonctionnait donc quand on fait une
bouture aux coupes en dessous d'une donc
là je vais couper en dessous là ensuite
comme j'ai dit on enlève ce qui est
inutile
c'est à dire les feuilles parce que ça
prend beaucoup d'énergie et là il faut
que l'énergie de la plante elle soit
très importante à la base pour pouvoir
produire des petites racines
donc là nous ce qu'on a voulu faire
c'est accompagné en fait les élèves dans
cette démarche de
de d'expérience cet accompagnement
scolaire n'est qu'une part du projet une
vie après l'autre les spécialistes du
jardin botanique de l'île de la réunion
vont eux aussi planter des boutures dans
les serres du jardin afin d'assurer un
résultat positif pour la multiplication
de sophie cus